it's that time of year to turn down the
lights put on a headset and play horror
games until your skin crawls but it's
also a good time to look ahead to the
frightening games yet to come
here's a list of our top 7 horror games
coming out in 2016 perception is a
first-person narrative horror adventure
perception comes from the deep end games
a group of previous Bioshock developers
led by Bill Gardner play as Cassie a
young woman investigating a mansion in
an abandoned estate but what makes it so
interesting is that she's blind she uses
what we might consider echolocation to
see so any sound creates a king giving
these sites the player will have to use
items like pain to create sounds to see
but you're also giving audio cues to
your location and you're being hunted in
a world filled with horror games where
jump scares and creepy masks are used
often perception has us rely on one of
the most frightening things of all the
unknown steam launch is planned for 2016
doom was one of the most influential and
popular video games in the early 90s and
the reboot by its software looks to be
just as fast brutal and gory as expected
it's technically a shooter but by no
means does it not have horror the series
focuses on the exploits of an unnamed
Space Marine opera
under the UAC who fights hordes of
demons and the undead in order to
survive from the dusty landscapes of
Mars to the blood-splattered depths of
Hell you'll be changing out weapons to
take down memorable threats like zombie
man
pinky demons and the Barons of Hell from
the gameplay we've seen it looks like
fast-paced frenetic carnage so far we
only have a release window of q1 or q2
in 2016 PC ps4 and Xbox one dragon is a
first-person psychological survival
horror game set on the north western
coast of Norway in 1923 Ragnar turn
quits development studio red thread
games have stated that it could be
compared to soma meets the vanishing of
Ethan Carter in a story inspired by
north mythology and New England gothic
you follow a dark and harrowing tale of
one man's descent into madness as he
investigates the disappearance of the
inhabitants of a small Norwegian coastal
community it looks like a slow burning
suspense thriller with an environment
that gave me the same chills as
Apocalypse
dragon is currently in development for
PC Mac Linux and next-gen consoles for
next year
Overkill's The Walking Dead is a co-op
first-person shooter with elements of
action role-playing survival horror and
stealth it invites players to explore
the hugely popular Walking Dead universe
while they'll play the role of a
survivor fending for themselves and a
post-apocalyptic world dominated by
flesh-eating walkers the game is in
development from the studio behind
payday the heist and will include
cooperative online gameplay and be paid
a esque according to The Walking Dead
creator Robert Kirkman the developers
are also working on a VR experience for
the game which will certainly seal the
deal on this frightening experience The
Walking Dead is planned for PC Xbox one
and ps4 last year we were treated to
outlast a surprising or game that really
pushed climatic tension and then aside
psychopaths and crazy experiments that
are gonna kill your the developers was
smart and got right to work on outlast 2
which will be a survival horror
experience and it will take place in the
same universe as outlast
but will have different characters in
two different settings Studio founder
Phillipe Marin told IGN that while the
game won't return players to the
pervasive darkness
of its predecessors Asylum setting the
night vision camera mechanic will return
and based off this trailer it's safe to
say there will be a new type of terror
in the night something that feeds off
the weak of creating a dark and twisted
horror that would leave you mad outlast
2 is planned for a fall 2016 release on
ps4 PC and Xbox one Allison Road is an
upcoming first-person survival horror
video game for PC created by British
developer Lilith limited and published
by team17 it's considered to be a
spiritual successor to PT the playable
teaser for the cancelled video game
silent hill's the player awakens in a
British townhouse with no memory as you
explore the house evidence is gathered
from letters and photos suggesting your
family has been a victim of a heinous
crime also you're not alone and as the
clock continues to tick towards 3:00
a.m. something in the house is stalking
you and making you question your sanity
the gameplay is just a small glimpse
into the world that we're afraid to
enter but it seems just too tempting to
ignore
the release date is TBA 2016 routine is
a first person horror exploration game
set on an abandoned moon base to remind
us of our nightmares from alien and
Space Odyssey the title is the debut
product of English indie studio lunar
software the storyline revolves around
the mysterious disappearance of the crew
members of the lunar research station to
uncover the truth players must travel
through the claustrophobic dark
corridors and rooms of the moon base
uncovering its secrets you won't find
first-aid kits because it's just alive
or dead in space and when I mean dead I
mean
kirmada your main tool is a cat
cosmonaut assistance tool just a repair
device that resembles a gun you upgrade
it with floppy disks found around the
base and in some cases you'll have to
use it as a last resort weapon between
being alone with nothing to calm your
never-ending imagination and being
hunted in a floating tube in space all
of your biggest fears are coming to life
routine has been a little quiet lately
but according to the last devlog it's
still deep in development for a hopeful
2016
so that's our list of seven games to
keep you up all night or at least keep
you at bay until next year happy
Halloween and happy gaming
you